the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok
on the take home exam you did very well
the I think the average it was 88 it's
very comfortable means everybody has
learned something so I think you USA
that I took a quick look at Jonathan
read very carefully and overall very
pleased I was impressed they're a lot of
math everybody reading done a lot of
formulas ok
ah so the last is best and after today
you can go out celebrate hopefully and
we have a new president you hear it ok
ah so what I was planning to talk about
is on the molecular dynamics simulation
and really how they emphasize in the
analysis of molecular dynamics
simulation so molecular dynamics
simulation computer see conceptually is
very easy right what we want is actually
most of the molecular dynamics
simulation nowadays is based on
classical molecular dynamics and in fact
people think it's done so the truth I
like this thick choke choke no more want
to use a different one
ok so they
classical molecular dynamics is F equals
MA right and so force equals MA so if I
have example a simulation box I have a
crystal I want to simulate its
properties and what I have Newton's
second law will tell you tell me the
mass of the ice atom MA so the
acceleration of the I see Adam equals
the force acting on the atom so we have
the force of all the other atoms J
equals 1 to n that's the N is the number
of atoms I'm simulating in the domain
and F I J so that's the force acting on
this specific atom and of course J
doesn't equal to I so that's the concept
right it's very easy and in fact you
have a anytime you give when you student
come in and say okay this is you sister
you start from here ah of course so you
can think about that your task is doing
integration of F equals MA and you make
sure that you have the proper potential
the force right remember the force
equals the gradient of the potential
right so we need a proper potential and
at least conceptually you have we have
discussed in this course different
potentials when there's potential ionic
potentials covalent potential so those
potential interactions and the reality
is for each different material when you
do classical molecular dynamics
simulation the different material people
have spent not a time
to put the proper potential so that they
can reproduce some of the matures basic
properties like a melting point when you
heat it up it melts and so all the
mechanical properties and because those
are not potential from first principle
when I say first principle is the
quantum mechanics right those are the
classical potential and typically you
start with some concept and you put in
the feeding parameters adjusted
parameter to refer to say these are the
best set of parameters for those matures
but we're not going into discussing how
to construct this potential people
typically if you are able to construct a
potential that's more general many
people use you have already achieved a
good success in this field it's not easy
to construct this potential and once you
have the potential of this second-order
derivative you have you have the
potential you do your integration right
and you want to find that the position
of the atoms molecules as a function of
time in your simulation domain so we can
do the integration so for example the
second order derivative we know let's
drop the vector notation so the second
order derivative drop the detector hi
and DT square equals RI and the T plus
delta-t
I use a central difference method for
example and plus our team I team as
delta T must to R I T this is a time
integration over and a to the other T
Square
right so if you go to check that the
accuracy of this this is actually of the
order of delta T this is the fourth
order so fourth power so that's the you
actually have a relatively high accuracy
when you use the central difference
method and then I can if I write this I
I can do your you take you choose a time
step so this is a explicit method you
choose a time step you advancing in time
to find the position of the atoms at the
next time so you use the say the next
times T plus delta T you use the
information previous time step the
current time step and previous time step
so I can integrate I say I can march in
time T plus delta T and what I have here
is then this one is if you look at the
Newton's second law is really just the F
divided by M so what I have here is a to
RI t months are I keep masculinity right
and then I have the derivative of the
acceleration which is to the other T
square times the force acting on this
atom in that specific Direction divided
the mass that's my acceleration and I
know if I do this what I my accurate
that is to do lucky fourth power that's
the I the terms that I dropped right so
this is a to the fourth power is a quad
high numerical accuracy and the what's
important is your time step right you
say okay I'm going to exer in my
integration I choose a very large time
step but
remember your time step has to be
smaller than the physical process that
goes on right if I have atoms to
oscillate it ten to the 14th hurt that
means 10 to the mass 14 second or period
then my delta T has to be if I want to
capture one period of the atom
oscillation you see that the sine
function I have to elicitor how accurate
that I say okay maybe I'll take one
tenth
that's not very fine points for a side
funky you know right so you can see then
easily you get two femtosecond very
small time steps and because of that
your integration time you want to
simulate the event that nozzle a no
second right and nanosecond ten to minus
nine you just start from 10 to minus 15
time step you can imagine that's a lot
of marching and other computation and
each time step you have to recalculate
the force because the atomic position
change and that will change the force
interactions so this is a time and with
this you can also calculate velocity
right velocity after the attempt T is
just the greedy derivative right so we
have the derivative of di DT then I have
RI T plus delta T which I calculate in
this time step and I have RIT and
divided by delta T and the disadvantage
of this compared to a central difference
this accuracy is lower it's only Chi
square and but the its lucky that this
is doesn't quad effect this does not in
fact does not affect in my calculation
of RI because my RI calculation is
indeed
and then of the velocity so my velocity
is not that accurate my position is much
more accurate depends on the time step
you take so that's easy right so I in
principle you can write a code and do
this calculation quickly and the key
question is how do you do your analysis
how you understand your analysis doing a
numerical simulation many times people
like to say I'm doing a numerical
experiment writing like that with
terminology but if you are doing
computation like this that you're doing
numerical experiment the question is how
you analyze your experiment right so
what are we going to discuss our focus
is really the statistical foundation for
numerical analysis oh one more comment
is before we go there is that when you
do molecular dynamics simulation already
set your time step has to be very short
let's say if you do solid you have to go
to femtosecond or even sub femtosecond
it depends on the oscillation frequency
of the atoms and the other is the Lambor
of atoms you can simulate right and if I
think about I want to similar 1 micron q
right and if you see the typical let's
say silicon silicon crystal right a
silicon crystal lattice constant is
about 500 so in a 5-ounce run cube there
are eight atoms and a 1 nano meter cube
that's say 8 times 8 is 64 and the one
micron is a 10 to the 9th power right
because the 3 order magnitude higher in
each the ratchet and that's a 10
lines times 64 that's a library of atoms
you got in one micron cube and with that
many time steps and that needs very high
powerful computer to even simulate one
micron so that's very hard and typically
people do a periodic boundary condition
so they try to similarly use a much
smaller simulation box right and you
have molecules or atoms in the box
and the next moment this atom can move
out of this simulation box and the way
that the cleverly taking into this
moving out is in the opposite direction
obviously boundaries so here it goes
other boundary and income seeing this
atom comes in at the position at the
velocity the corresponding position on
the opposite boundary and the velocity
that they exit so this is the trick that
people use periodic boundary condition
and with that you hope to recapture the
effects of infinite simulation right any
time you use a purely boundary condition
you actually say in the specific
direction where it's periodic is
infinite and there are also artifacts
that's caused by this periodic boundary
condition as you will see very much
easier once we get into this to tease
your aspects and let's look into the
statistical foundation
and first in chapter 4 we when we do the
statistics we introduce the concept of
an example average right in the old days
you do not actually trace the trajectory
the time trajectory of atoms remember
molecular dynamics is looking the way we
describe is looking to the time
trajectory of the atoms and when we
discuss the statistic we said that's too
complicated that we're actually going to
do in sample average rather than time
average right and then we introduced the
concept of ergodicity our system for a
Gothic system the in-sample average
equals the time average right so the
time of course with a time average if I
have a quantity and this quantity is the
quantity in phase space for example is a
position a momentum of many particles I
am just using our representative may be
millions of billions of atoms position a
moment corresponding momentum and when I
do the time average of this quantity I
say this is I observe this quantity over
a certain period of time starting any
time T plus delta T so this whole region
if I do my average correctly in this
origin doesn't matter so here I have
this as our a that the phase space
variable for example I can write the
potential energy or kinetic energy or
total energy in terms of the energy of
every particles and that I this is the
total energy I a verge it over a certain
amount of time right so here this R
remember is a function of time momentum
is a function of time and I integrate
and that that's a definition I if I look
long enough I get my average quantity
energy or momentum or pressure right the
shear stress all those three quantities
of the system so this is the time
averaging and then when I do the
in-sample average right inside by
average of this quantity I use a bracket
and remember in sample averages is I
look at the probability function right
we see microcanonical annika example
each each of the system in the example
is the equal probability kilala in some
boards boards my distribution or we also
introduce where the gives a example
there were there is not only constant
temperature but also mass flow flux with
the ambient right so at the end when I
do the in sample average I averaged over
the probability right so the the in
sample average is I will have this phase
space variable R and P and then I
integrate over the place space variables
and then I have my probability
distribution right for n particle in the
system and the r and p and i would this
is my integration in I to double I
really mean many because the R and P is
all the particles momentum and position
so a guarding a system means my time
averaged eCourse in sample average right
and in the pasta we had really follow
this trajectory we were going to solve
both my equation I
simplify this and part of your
distribution function into one part of
your distribution function and I do the
averaging velocity or heat flux as we
have been doing and we do molecular
dynamics you are simulating time
trajectory so you're really interested
how I'm going to do the time average to
get the quantities that have been
interesting for example if I want to
compute the thermal connectivity with
gasa T of the system right I will look
at the atomic positions as a function of
time now how I can extract this
information that I'm interesting so
those are the questions and let's look
at I am interested in the property right
thermal conductivity electrical activity
and so in general those are the response
if I so let's discuss the response
function
and let me look into a system that is
initially at the equilibrium so system
equilibrium system and the system
mahomet onea write the Hamiltonian
typically you can understand the
Hamiltonian as the kinetic energy plus
the potential energy so the system of
Hamiltonian is H 0 equilibrium let's say
the volume is a way and then I'm going
to give a disturbance to the system
right I push the system I push it every
atom oh I I somehow inject some heat so
right now my disturbance I'm going to
say I'm going to give a small
disturbance and the uniform through this
space and this doesn't really matter you
can extend to long uniform but because I
have a perturbation due to a force so I
use a foster to perturb it and because
I'm applying force the system
Hamiltonian the energy of the system
will change and that change is H prime
right small change so I will say this is
the perturbation to the Hamiltonian of
the system and I can write this
perturbation because this is the force
apply so this will be related to the to
the position and kinetic energy or of
the each atom in the system right so
this relation Hamiltonian is expressed
in this perturbation and this is the
force apply and a dual / ization to the
volume so I have my volume there and I
put a leg this time that doesn't matter
because that could be absorbed into it
right so this is my perturbed
Hamiltonian and now so this this is
really the water is the perturbing due
to this force to individual atoms or
molecules right and sometime later I
want to look at the response I want to
look at how the heat flux change how the
shear stress change right and the the
shear stress again is reflected by
another quantity let's say this is a B
again is the individual phase space
variable right and this one this is the
response this is the disturbance right
so in the case where the system is
linear my force is a lot very large then
this response I know what be
proportional to the force right so this
is a linear disturbance linear response
regime and my so what I have is this is
my force either apply a certain time T
prime and that this force could be
continuously varying time varying and
then from the start of time to the
current time because this R and the T of
the atoms in this system could be a
function of time is changing because
apply the external force right and this
is just related to a response function
here and that's the function that I'm
interested so be a and this is T prime
this I'm looking at at T time T so T
must be prime so this is that the
instant is acted and after some time
what's my system response
what's this response this quantity is
responding right it's just that the only
assumption I have here is a linear small
disturbance so that this response is
proportional to the first power of my
force so here this be a say Phi is after
effective action
it's a general describe what happens
after apply a disturbance to the system
right so it should be a real observed as
a real quantity and this is in fact that
is also sometimes you probably someone
who heard the causality right F is the
cause and later on it has a response so
you should not just result a general you
cannot divide it violate and those are
the causality real requirement okay so
what we have written is in real time and
of course you can always express those
properties in the frequency domain you
can do the Fourier transform of force
and if you do your fuller transform and
we have here and I should do the sample
average I want to look at the Equality
Fourier transform and then I can use the
Fourier space response and I'm not going
to derive it but this can be proven and
at be a so this is a disturbance start
with a and the super disturbed quantity
due to their force and the response is a
specific response for example like I
said viscosity
so here is a frequency and the force is
also Fourier transform and exponential I
Omega T and D Omega so you can say that
this our susceptibility that we use
record the lam accessibility of the
system must be related to the
aftereffect function here right in fact
this susceptibility so here we have the
lam except G led of the system x da
Omega is actually the Fourier transform
awful so it's 0 to infinite Phi be a how
exponent sure must I when we got how
Etan so if I know this I know the after
if a function or if I know after it's a
function and notice has a bit ability
okay
and in fact that there is a really
interesting relation between this one
could be real part and imaginary part
because I'm here I have in the Fourier
transform I have idea right so I have a
real part I have an imaginary part I can
write ok I have real part plus i
measuring part and both a frequency
dependent and you can say because this
is really just a cosine on side part of
the Fourier transform if I do a cosine
so if you had not real part of this
frequency dependence I can go inverse
cosine transform and get this function
here from this function I can do a sine
transform I can get the imaginary part
right so which means the real I imagined
always related and this relation is the
Crammer chronicle relation it's very
general if you do thermal radiation
radiation I
you probably heard a for example the
dielectric constant or optic constant
you can calculate if you measure real
part you can calculate measuring part if
you measure imagined power you can
conquer real part
let's example of the crowning kramer
chronicle relation and so the real part
for example can be calculated from a you
measuring part and minus infinity to
plus infinity you measuring power Omega
Prime and Omega prime minus Omega D
Omega pride so you can say the problem
of this integration is that when Omega
prime equals Omega because I'm
integrating from Madison velocity
infinite this blew up so this has to be
this is a in the fryer you put a Cauchy
principle value so actually there is a
negative sign for this part and let's
just say when they are going from left
approaching to Omega or from right
approaching the Omega is separated with
a limit either this singularity point
and similarly there is relation you
switch the there's no more sign it's a
positive sign you switch this with this
you get another relation so either way
if you know the real I'm not imagining
part but you need to see if you look at
this function here you need to know the
whole function at the function of
frequency right if you just have if you
do after measurement and you're not only
a section of that you may not be
accurate enough to do this inverse using
the grammar chronicle relation
and there's enough this is a causality
what sometimes people say this is a
causality requirement right you can see
that so we don't have assumptions there
and what's also interesting right if you
say this is a response on different
faith based variable but if a B is the
same as a right and a is related to the
because the a is here is a disturbance
to the Hamiltonian right the energy of
the system so in fact when B equals a
there's a useful relation that's a P
equals a and what we have is the energy
dissipated in this system due to this
external disturbance right and the
eCourse is related to the imaginary part
of the dynamics as a possibility so let
me go over to V X a a so B equals a now
the imagined part and Omega F Omega
square so this is a just result out of
again the modality and in general its
general okay and here we're discussing
the response function and next let's
move on so I have now the system has a
small perturbation H Prime and initially
it was at a uniform situation right we
have F say the H zero and now after this
perturbation the distribution function
will change right because of the
Hamiltonian of the system change and
distribution function
so now I'm you see the approach I've
mentioned before one of those approach
is going to boards my equation the Fon
the Empire distribution function is
reduced to one particle distribution
function and that's the board's my
equation approach and what are we going
in this approach is an inny arise is
actually taking the in particle
distribution function so the linear
response Theory start from the low
voiding and but it's a ninny arises logo
equation but still keep the end particle
distribution so if we go back to the
Louisville equation and this is a little
bit equation written in operator form so
the lovo equation is the equation for
the end particle distribution function
as the function of time and we could
write this in operator so it's a H the
Hamiltonian of the system and the F n
this bracket is called the Poisson
bracket of explain would admit mathema
see and then see there's also another
location and this is a using I gamma
operator and the F and ok here the point
is I'm writing a Louisville equation
with and this is original no-go equation
with an particle distribution function
and and notation wise whether we have on
the right hand side first as the curve
curly bracket is a person brought here
and that's just a location if you have a
and B and what it means is because I
have pi e Parker so i equal to 1 2 in
fact say these are the total number of
degree freedom if I have capital in
particular and the ischium particular
each particle has a 3 degree that's
Austrian if it's a 6 degree is the 16
right so this is a ok and then I have da
and D RI d b DP i minus da epi
DP g RI and with this notation you put
in back into the right hand side that
you get back to the original louisville
equation that we have written down
before okay and this one gamma here is
an operator so gamma is a is definition
is the operator is month I and H and
whatever behind this function is put in
here this is the operator notation okay
and that they are use of the this is the
Louisville operator the use of this
Louisville operator is now with this
written as this form you can just think
this is like an ordinary differential
equation okay and you have to go in back
into all this detailed math but think
this eyes the ordinary differential
equation you solve it as a exponential
function that's the use of less noble
and of course that gamma you keep it as
an operator form and and now so what do
we have the system Hamiltonian is H 0
plus h prime
right I have a perturbation to the
system energy and then correspondingly
the end particle distribution function
is f 0 and that's corresponding to
equilibrium and then small perturbation
F 1 and that due to the perturbation H
Prime and F 0 n is related to because I
the equilibrium so it's a you can write
it as H KBT as a boards most
distribution there right at full system
at so the way that I'm reading here F 0
here is a canonical distribution
canonical system right and so once I
have those I put in here into this
equation I use the operator and I legal
act the the term illegal actor is H
prime times F 1 because that's a H prime
is lower order smooth disturbance FY is
more disturbance so I drop that cross
term that's a higher order and with that
I can solve for F 1 in the operator
notation
so I will have f1 and and a tea our P is
the phase space variable D is Ave KBT
that comes of a cavity comes from F 0 n
and minus infinite 2t and exponential
minus i TMS T Prime huama right if you
look at this exponential that come from
I treated at gamma just like a constant
I do integration that's the operator
math there and gamma 0 this gamma 0 is
corresponding to when H is H 0 and then
I have the time derivative of this
because H prime has a so I have time
derivative in the a I have R is a
function of time and P is a function of
time that's why I can do the time
derivative and I have F T Prime and this
is a to Oh T Prime and then I have F 0
to N and the D T Prime so this is the
solution to the perturbed distribution
function and part of your distribution
function remember gamma is an operator
it looks simple but it's operator and
for this operator in fact if you want to
operate what's the function behind you
have to expand this into back into using
the Taylor expansion so that you can you
can't just put this stuff inside that
you :
okay so the what the use of this is once
I have this former solution I can go
back to calculate they are in sample
average right because my assembly
average is an equality in terms of the
momentum and the location of the system
times distribution function now
distribution function considers a for
equilibrium part and the perturbation
part right in most of transport if I
deal with the transport I know that you
can you prevent apart or drop out and
this is the deviation part that gives me
the response right so I do this I I go
to calculate and for example we were
writing this before the response would
be you can say this is once you do the
substitute into the unparticle averaging
expression at the end of what you get
the DT prime F T prime that's day and
then here we have away KBT by KBT and
integration of for F 0 n and then we
have would be R T T and the exponential
mass eye-team us t prime gamma 0 a dot
and here I have our T prime P T Prime
and the d-r-e P okay and here the
bracket and the reason I'm writing into
this form is because inside the bracket
is my after effect function right this
is the disturbance this is the response
I'm interesting the quantity of response
and the this one is my after effect
function due to that disturbance that
created the a which is the phase
function in the Hamiltonian so this one
is my after effect of function be a team
s T prime as I defined before right here
I have a team as T prime and if you use
further the operator notation of the
this one the operator properties you can
get the following so here we're not
going to write all the derivation now
this is a pretty lot of writing I want
to appreciate right because I said
before you have boards my approach you
have a linear response Theory approach
an inner response theory is really
developed after the computational power
say in combination with the
computational techniques so t minus T
prime now the if you look like this it
could be they KBT after you actually do
this operation use that as the operator
properties and we can say here is the F
0 n and a dot that's a time derivative
RT prime P 2 prime and look at the time
or eg is important be
here is our team us t prime because of
this operator and the p t minus T prime
so now this is the quantity in the time
before at dr PP right here you can see
this is this phase space average because
here is a distribution function you can
either distribution function and this
disturbance is out it actually does not
get into my a does not get into my B it
is independent of that disparate
disturbance this is the one I do a
thermal conductivity with casa T is a
physical property of the system right
and this is a statistical the in sample
average because here that's what we defy
and this is the quantity at two
different time so this is a cross
correlation function and with this you
can convert also back into the time
because we say is a gothic system right
here is in second sample average now you
can convert back into the time average
so we could write this KBT that's the in
sample average of quantity T must t
prime and the quantity I the T prime
derivative and this is a if this time
origin is not important so you can write
T and the a added this origin you choose
whatever time is zero and now and this
one there are different ways to write it
you can write V KBT and rather than the
derivative of a you can write in
it evolved II and time T and this all
can be proven I'm just giving you the
expression and what they mean so here is
all time averaging these in sample
averaging but when I do a molecular
dynamics I do the time averaging because
so what it means is I have this in Samba
averaging is equal to time averaging so
T prime plus P and a T prime right so
the bar in the up is the time averaging
as we introduced so now we have so you
can simulate an equilibrium system and
get the properties really responds
because the force is taken out okay and
with this of course you know the
aftereffect function you can get the
frequency component right as we have
written down the susceptibility as from
your frequency and in fact if you write
further because the susceptibility now
can be calculated as here if I look at
this one the autocorrelation when a goes
to itself
that's an autocorrelation when go to
different quantity it's a cross
correlation right so now the imaginary
part can be related to the
autocorrelation function when B equals a
and what do you have here that from that
expression I can write the imaginary
part of the susceptibility as a function
of frequency is V Omega and 2 KBT and
mass infinitive plus in for the
exponential minus I Omega T and a
either t a0 DT so from the
cross-correlation the autocorrelation I
can calculate imaginary part and this is
I mentioned it many times this is
actually the fluctuation dissipation
theorem this is the fluctuation
autocorrelation the imaginary part is
the dissipation because that imagined
part is related to the energy dissipated
in the system right so this is the
fluctuation dissipation theorem general
form and when I do
for example near field radiation
simulation I do we use a lot of this
fluctuation dissipation syrup and what I
do is the card to fluctuation is related
to imaginary part of the dielectric
constant that's one example of the
fluctuation dissipation theorem and if
you do the quantum you can generalize in
the quantum limit and what you have here
the imagined part you will have to write
this as the H bar and the cotangent say
this is a hyperbolic cotangent function
H bar Omega 2 KB T and minus infinity
plus infinity minus I Omega T and a key
a zero so that's a the quantum form of
modification of fluctuation dissipation
here okay so
now this is the the essence of the Nene
response and what I need the lecture is
to give you three examples for example
how I can relate the electric
conductivity and calculate the based on
the if I have ions in this system right
so writing down the corresponding form
so if I have ions in the system and I
apply a electric field to the system and
the issue so now the each ions will be C
do it so the fielder will give a force
force will move they are in force times
distance it gives me the work right
that's the additional energy that the
system is subjected perturbation and so
we have them look either the
perturbation in Hammond Tony can be
written as I equals 1 to N and particles
and the displacement RI you can do RI
minus r0 let's say then r0 is the
original Hamiltonian right so it's RI
and then the force is the charge so I
have the ice atom has a CD ions Zi
charge and I have then e which is a
function of time right
this is the perturbation and from here
going back to the definition I know my a
because I want to express a in terms of
the phase variable right this should
equal to according to my definition - a
way e which is my disturbance and so my
a here the equation - way Sigma I equals
1 to n zi e RI ok and I can look at a
for example current what's my response
right giving a electric field I want to
look at what's the current in the system
so my current of the system is the
charge times velocity right so the
current in the system is charge times
velocity so zi e + d RI dt i equals 1 to
n right and so i do in terms of with a
per unit volume again and you can say
here i was a little bit that I'm trying
to reconcile my sigh I haven't be able
to reconcile my sign so I write this as
the gradient because here is dr/dt here
is dr/dt right okay so with that I can
then now look at that this is
essentially this is the response amount
to look at and that's my B right so I
have a I have B and now I can write they
use the
the expression we have the aftereffect
function and in fact what we have here
is if I write into the frequency for J
Omega equals the electric conductivity
which is usually tensile okay thermal
Canada is 10 so electrical data visit
ENSO and six component and is related to
the potential product to the electric
field right that's the response and this
is the after effect that's the frequency
component here is a real time component
and that's a frequency expression and I
can use the real time real component and
so what I have here then the electric
conductivity
so the electric conductivity if you use
what we have here is can be written
particularly if I do isotropic I can
write each direction but now I do
isotropic so then I don't have the auto
tensor component only diagonal and in
that case I can average so it's 3 KBT
and 0 in fun j xt j 0 j x 0 + + j y t j
y at x 0 j ZT j z x 0 x 0 is the origin
you choose and then i have exponential
mass I Omega T DT so this is my
frequency component of the electric
conductivity of this system I simulated
so in a real simulation you solve F
equals MA if you know the force
interaction between these atoms and the
ones you have that you write the time
derivative that's your current of flux
and then you calculate does the time
autocorrelation function and they will
see once order because I say isotropic
is so that I'm averaging over three
directions right so this is in fact what
we have here is the green COBOL
formulation this is the green COBOL
formula bring Coble formula
and we can write from the say we are
calculated a type response and from
there we can calculate also the
frequency it's a simple frequency the
Fourier transform okay
and green COBOL is they didn't write one
paper they develop this but as
independently each other so this is the
case for the electric or the expression
final expression for the electric
conductivity and in fact as a to derive
a green Cobell formula for thermal
conductivity was not easy and the reason
for that is in this case the derivation
process we were using the system might
have an external disturbance F right and
the thermal is a internal disturbance
the thermal fluctuation of this system
and there are many derivations the
cleanest derivation which doesn't have
any simple any physical see meaning was
actually using gravitational field to
drive the molecule as a disturbance and
derive the heat flux correlation but say
what do we need is a so the book I I
want to present this in fact I'm still
not very comfortable about that section
so what we have the for thermal
disturbance and the distribution
function is exponential minus a we can
write exponential the hamiltonian h the
energy a small volume and a KB T plus
delta T let's suppose so what I'm
looking at it is the temperature
fluctuation inside the system because of
the hampshire fluctuation the local
energy has a fluctuation
and I want to write that what's the H
Prime the case I want to write a watch H
prime right and with this distribution
either and that I can write from here I
can write an H prime equals if I need
arise it is the H itself which is the
energy Hamiltonian which is a function
of position and velocity for example is
T the other t which could be function of
R and T and D integration over the
volume so this is a my H prime right and
then you have to plug in this H prime
and go back to the derivation and find
that what's that f 1 okay and in the
process I have to use energy
conservation and then I will see then
you have to integrate over the volume
when you're considering and what's the
boundary condition you check and I
looked into many books I was never
satisfied and I put what I finally say I
have to complete this so you can check
my book and so either if you do this
what you have is you will derive a
thermal conductivity tensor and this is
because I have now a delta T in the
system right temperature fluctuation and
from temperature this delta T I can
eventually derive a thermal conductivity
tensor that is a way KB T Square as they
are 0 to infinity and the heat flux
expression either Tao and the
autocorrelation of heat flux between 0
and tau exponential mass I only got how
beat how so this is the Green Coble
expression for thermal conductivity and
thermal conductivity self again could be
a function of frequency
there's a lot more when we do heat we
don't do very high
temperature high frequency so this is a
in fact that this is related to the
continuity equation but continuity
equation is level correct I made a
comment before well it's very hard to be
correct because when you have a very
fast temperature distribute a
temperature disturbance you typically
have a special temperature gradient and
if that gradient is a longer shorter the
mean free path you can just use
continuity equation so what you should
do is actually write both the frequency
and space dependent so time and space
dependence thermal conductivity and that
gives you long no course thermal
conductivity which would be not only a
fun your frequency but also be a
functional wave vector nobody has done
that ok I'm just telling I think that
should be the case and in fact I say you
see the derivation I had before the F I
said the system is a uniform form force
here that disturbance temperature could
be spatially dependent if there's
special dependence that you can write
actually a corresponding space
dependence wave vector and frequency
dependent expression thermal
conductivity ok so now you have green
COBOL and the beauty you should see here
the beauty is it's an equilibrium
simulation you simulate a system box up
there even though we say the derivation
process I have external force but I
and all those transfer of property is I
don't have a disturbance anymore I say
external force anymore
I just can simulate the equilibrant
system and do my autocorrelation
function and calculate transfer
properties with casa t all those but you
have to have the expression for what's
the microscopic Jake hill in the case of
car and I have expression here right so
deriving this microscopic expression for
the quantity that of your interest
is a the next step so what are those
microscopic quantities right so for
example Connecticut energy
I want to calculate that's very easy say
I equals 1 to N and the TI square to em
all right right and you can write the
kinetic potential Hamiltonian add up
kinetic and potential so simple ones
easy and for heat flux and they are also
extruder heat and mass flux in fact is
very easy right the mass flux is just
the quantity is the m/v I will say mi VI
and the I equals 1 to n and then now if
you do your heat flux and the heat flux
is I equals 1 to N and VI si is the
enthalpy of per molecule or atom you're
dealing with and plus one-half of the
interaction I equals J equals 1 gee
that's not equal to I and and RI J
that's the distance between the two
atoms and the F I J dot V I so this one
is this expression is actually derived
them from the really you write the
energy conservation for each atom and in
the process you can derive the
expression microstructure you get
expression for the thermal the heat flux
okay
and the there so there are many
different microscopic expression for
different quantities the final comment I
want to make is when you simulate so
here in the derivation linear response
theory I am doing actually a canonical
system right constant temperature now
when you do a molecular dynamic
simulation you typically fixham a number
of atoms you try maintain the energies
constant right and then when you have a
constant energy constant volume constant
number of molecules what you have you
have a micro canonical example right so
how you can do a micro canonical
simulation and yet to represent that I'm
simulating system at constant
temperature or I'm simulating system at
constant pressure and this is a people
I've spent a lot of time trying to deal
with that question and here is the so
how you stack some oerstadt are the
example thermal thermal study and
samples
okay so to do this you actually also
have to get used to the fact that
normally you do F equals MA right that's
the equation of motion but there are
many different ways that write the F
equals MA and there are linear equation
of motion Hamiltonian equation motion
they are all equivalent I'm not not even
not grungy equation of motion and
Hamiltonian so for example when you do a
log Ranjan equation of motion right and
woody use is our our dot okay let's say
you you use this the velocity at space
as you see as your variable and you
construct the Lagrangian of the system
which is a function of the time function
of our function of velocity and
Lagrangian of the system is our r dot
much the potential energy so it's
kinetic energy mass potential energy
maybe you learn this in dynamics and so
the Hamiltonian principal so what's the
like larger equation of motion is there
is this Hamiltonian principle see when
your system go from point one to point
two the Lagrangian so the integral here
integer this is the action integral from
1 to 2 of the Lagrangian and T are our
dot and they integrate over time and
this should be a
Stremme its maximum minimum and in fact
I don't know whether it should be
maximum minima let's say it's derivative
is zero
okay derivative zero from there you do
variation you actually get the equation
of motion for the Lagrangian so you do
your here you do the equation of motion
then you will get this is extrema you
get a dl d R here I have I'm writing in
each component the velocity and the l dr
is equal to zero so this is actually F
equals MA under the Lagrangian okay the
Lagrangian is useful but it has a one
defect it's not symmetric okay it lacks
the symmetry and so if you rather than
use the r and r dot if you use the R and
the P this will come back to the phase
space right if you use the position and
momentum and you actually can do a
transformation into the Hamiltonian
equation motion
so you can write rather than using our
if you do your new variable P momentum
if you define equals the slug Ranjan
derivative that's a momentum and you can
go write the Cartesian coordinate you'll
find this all come back to fuq ma
everything makes sense and then you can
construct your Hamiltonian T R P so now
my variable in Lagrangian is the r and r
dot in hamiltonian is r and p right so
in the so this is sigma PL d riri13 in
this simple a say case a powerful
kinetic plus potential is essentially if
you in cartesian coordinate your is a
kinetic energy plus potential energy
this is the whether we keep everything
about the company okay and once you have
the hamiltonian you write the the
equation of motion for hamiltonian is
our i and our date so the momentum
derivative and space derivative is d h
DP i so this one you can say compared to
Lagrangian equation motion this is a
hamiltonian equation of motion the
momentum a space derivative and they are
symmetric so that's a the Hamiltonian is
often are used why I'm saying this why I
don't see I'm going into rather than F
equals MA Lagrangian and Hamiltonian
that's because well sometimes the for
example if you write if you do a
simulation of molecules right the
molecule of a diatomic molecule has a of
course each model has two atoms if you
say I'm going to simulate just our
position and velocity I have I split I
have to split this molecule into two
atoms right but see I can use theta C
the angle rotation and the relative
vibration so in that case I have
different variable different momentum
different coordinate so the beauty of
the Hamiltonian is you can write that
much easier now what's the relation to
this my original question I want to my I
do a simulation
that's a micro canonical example right
and how I can simulate a canonic using a
Kalon si to actually do a canonical
system with the constant temperature and
the trick here is this was a creating
artificial Hamiltonian okay
so for example knows introduce
Hamiltonian and the Hamiltonian he wrote
this is a hero that are not only are but
also additional variable and the P prime
momentum and the PS okay and in his
Hamiltonian the time is T Prime and then
they say it's not even the real time the
time is Reyes a related to so it's face
DT equals s DT so you have this addition
er s is your equivalent of one of the R
and then you have a P additional
momentum that was introduced
and he say this one equals Sigma I to n
P I prime P i prime and 2m s square plus
potential energy is still the real space
but he has the additional add another
term this momentum so is this a 2m n so
and plus here is a F plus 1 and KBT log
s P cook this up ok and the reason you
cook this up is you write a Hamiltonian
you can write the equation of motion ok
and then you see if I simulate this
system even though I simulator is a
micro canonical example at the end I get
a canonical example result for the
original system so he actually proved it
so the way you prove it in a micro
canonical example you remember the
entropy is the K log Omega right Omega
is Lambor of states right so number of
states is really just dr DP prime and
then now I have extra DSD PS right and
then they this is a counting number
state so is when the energy of the
system is equal to the Hamiltonian that
Delta I have one state right so this
integration is just a summation what it
says so starting from here using this
Hamiltonian you integrate the s and the
P Prime PS right those are the two extra
he introduced he actually show that
after you integration what you have here
is the say nf+ one this is last equation
I'm going to write 2 pi M n KB T 1/2
exponential e KBT I saw this was a
beautiful the people actually concern
those ways of doing things that's why I
want to write to you and this is the H R
P and KB T so you see the trick is he
actually going from this Delta he was
able to integrate that dsdp and because
he had this log here right in the
equation of motion he had this log he
got the exponent and it can work back
into here is your board my statistics
right and you can also prove if you do a
quantity of a and the RC dot to the time
average is the same as in sample average
except the nose who had that one problem
because so it was later Hoover said this
was not necessary and going back to
actually go to real space and I actually
saw his problem so it's called this is
called elusive on hope thermostat right
and there are people develop us say for
example Anderson is available a
thermostat where you can create a
constant pressure system so you have
different equation with that you can
write different equation of motion so
that you add essentially one equation
into the system of n particles you can
solve the using that you can deal with
the constant temperature constant
pressure
different constructions in samples okay
how 30
I thought I was going to show some
slides but remember if you haven't done
your evaluation see at least I use time
up thank you